at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by fresh books man oh man
do a lot of listeners of this podcast
and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with
the CEO not very long ago why are they
so popular well they are the number one
cloud accounting software designed
exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers a lot
of on type windows and beyond you can
take pictures of receipts you can link
your credit card and debit cards so all
the things you buy automatically appear
in your fresh books in the right
category so on and so forth makes taxes
easy makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put the other PDF a
while back called breaking the time
barrier subtitle how to unlock your true
earning potential so you can search for
breaking the time barrier a lot of
people ask me how can I get a 4-hour
workweek with the service business and
the story in that ebook its PDF is the
short answer it's really really good so
I think you should also check that out
so breaking the time error check it out
but also why not test out fresh books
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial at fresh ebooks.com forward slash
tim and enter tim ferriss two hours in
two S's in the how did you hear about us
section that sounds like we're gonna get
very little tracking that's a lot of
work but just go to fresh books calm
forward-slash tim and try it out because
it is a very good product and i think
you will find it simplifies your life
enjoy
this episode is brought to you by soothe
dot-com the world's largest on-demand
massage service I have been broken so
many times over the years that I usually
have body work done at least once a week
I have a very very high bar for this
type of thing and I was very skeptical
of soothe until I tested them not once
but I would say at least a dozen times
around the country in different cities I
do not accept anything less than
excellent for any type of soft tissue
treatment and I would not suggest that
you accept anything less than excellent
so I can affirm personally that soothe
delivers a licensed experienced and
above all effective in my book massage
therapist in the comfort of your own
home hotel or office in as little as an
hour so you can think of it as uber for
massages available and 55 cities
worldwide at this point across the US UK
Canada and Australia so you can relax
just about any time any where and I've
tried many different types of massage
that they offer in the process is super
super simple download the soothe app
that's soo th e or go to soothe calm
choose the kind of massage you want you
can select Swedish sports deep tissue or
even couples massage I usually do deep
tissue myself or I'll do couples massage
and then tell both of the therapists
that I'm actually intending to get a
four-handed massage instead of it having
two people get two hand massages if that
makes sense then you set the length of
your massage whether 60 90 or 120
minutes if you're looking to get fixed I
usually do 90 or ideally 120 you select
the gender of your therapist and then
boom you're done and you will see who
picks up the call the service is
available from 8 a.m. to midnight and
soothe brings everything that you need
to create a spa experience in your home
and the therapist handles all of this
the massage table linens oils music the
whole nine yards so try it out download
soothe and as a listener of this show
you'll get twenty five dollars off of
your first massage when you enter the
code Tim twenty five all caps T I am to
five again download the suit
and use the code Tim 25 for your $25
discount hello boys and girls
Damas Y Caballeros this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where does my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types from philosophy
chess business entertainment you name it
academia research to tease out the
habits routines favorite books favorite
cereals morning routines whatever it
might be that I think is tactical
practical that you can apply to your own
life and my guest today is Whitney Wolfe
heard on Instagram you can say hello at
wit Wolfe heard whi t wo l FP h ER d she
is the founder and CEO of bumble one of
the fastest growing social networking
apps in the world she launched bumble in
2014 is the only dating platform where
women make the first move and in three
years counted out 36 months her vision
has led to bumbles growth to more than
28 million users worldwide in 144
countries bumble launched bumble bee FF
that's best friends forever
bumble bee FF in 2016 as a friend
finding feature and launched bumble biz
twosies for professional networking in
2017 wolf herd was named to Forbes 30
under 30 list for 2018 and has recently
been on the covers of not just fast
company but also Forbes and wired
magazines without further ado please
enjoy this conversation with Whitney
wolf hurt
Whitney welcome to the show thanks for
having me
a local hello you are last in Texas yeah
so I wanted to start at the beginning
and for those people who aren't familiar
with the a bit of the Genesis story and
also the name itself so how did bumble
come to be why did it come to be so
bumble is somewhat of a unique story in
the sense that it wasn't just a singular
aha moment somewhere it was really a
response to a couple different things in
life and then there was a little bit of
serendipity involved I had just started
becoming the you know kind of the center
of this attacking you know violent
internet abuse and all sorts of
strangers and random people online were
just ripping me apart all day long in
the media and in the comment sections
and on Twitter and it sounds silly to
think that that could affect you oh no
I've been on the receiving end of that
yeah but it devastated me and it made me
just it just made me so depressed and I
started to realize that there was
something wrong with the Internet I
started to realize that the lack of
accountability on these social networks
that was a real thing and there was a
real risk to that and I was I was on you
know I was a perfect example of how
dangerous it could be and if I at 24 who
had already had somewhat you know
successful career and had great friends
and family around me and I still could
barely get out of bed and I could barely
see straight I mean it just it depleted
every every ounce of confidence that
I've ever ever had it scared me for what
it would mean for a 13 year old or 14
year old or 15 year old who was in
junior high going through this right and
so I started to really understand the
danger of the Internet and it was around
that time that I started thinking what
am I going to do next because obviously
I'm not gonna you know just do nothing
at 25 after being part of this really
high-growth startup and having this you
know awesome exposure to so many diff
areas of the tech industry and so I was
going to start a female only social
network where you can only be kind to
one another so you can only share
complementary behavior and the thought
process behind it was compliments are
contagious
just like hatred is contagious what was
it going to be called merci messy yeah
thank you
right so it was supposed to be a kind
social network which had never been done
and it was around that time that things
kind of parlayed into where we are now
my now business partner in bumble who's
been a huge force and you know bumble
coming to life and and the the course of
bumble he tried to hire me as his CMO at
his dating company he is this huge
dating company that's the match of
Europe and South America his name is
Andre andreev and best name ever ever
right so James Bond yeah he's he's
pretty awesome but he he wanted me to go
run marketing and his dating company and
I thought he had lost his mind and so I
told him what I was going to do I'm
gonna start this new way you know this
new age of social media and he was like
no you're not you're gonna do that in
dating with me and I was like you've
lost your mind
but we actually ended up talking through
it and the more thought I gave to this
new concept of a dating app that could
be engineered for women by women then
the need became more apparent and so
that's how I shifted from this concept
of mercy into what is now bumble which
was you know very much a similar concept
if you think about it you know creating
a brand ridding kindness a product
rooted in good behavior and really
putting women in charge of that creating
the female Internet and that was really
the the beginning of bumble what was it
it was the first name of a bumble or
weird anomaly Moxie yes it was I really
wanted to be Moxie so you know for
anyone that's familiar with that word it
it's that you know in sending a it says
someone has gall or guts and his brave
and because bumble was going to be this
platform turning society on its head
we're women
we're going to make the first move
which according to society that's not
something women should do definitely not
in dating right I mean it's a tale as
hold of time men do that men need to go
first or so society said and says and so
Moxie was going to be the name that I
couldn't trademark it
why couldn't you trademark him there
somebody else had totally trademarked
every corner of it it's actually a soda
somewhere and then there's some big PR
firm or some consulting agency that's
trademarked the heck out of it and I
couldn't do it so how did he land on
bumble then I actually hated the name
bumble at first I thought bumble how did
it occur to you I did not think of the
name bumble actually someone on our Lee
team did and she had actually called her
husband a bumbling idiot and she's got
this British accent she was like you
know what about bumble because we had
all been searching the internet we
literally putting random letters
together to come up with words I mean
anything what were the other top
contenders oh goodness I've come leap
yeah because women we're gonna take the
leap and make the first move and
actually leap year is a very interesting
story so in leap year folklore says that
women would propose to men during the
year and so we thought leap and then we
you know we played with Sadie for like
Sadie Hawkins dance we played with lady
Hawkins down you don't know what the
Sadie Hawkins dance I'm getting a lot of
a looks for surprised okay this is
awesome yeah so the Sadie Hawkins dance
started in the 1930s and it was based
off of a cartoon by Al Capp where these
women during leap year would make the
first move essentially they they'd ask
them in to marry them and this got
consolidated into a dance that US school
system started putting into place and it
became so popular you know the Sadie
Hawkins they'd wear the poodle skirts
and the black and white shoes okay
you're gonna have to look into this but
now is it dance it's it's it's not an
actual dance it's not like a mating
ritual dance it no it's it's like a
school dance so you have the prom right
and then you had the Sadie Hawkins dance
and the Sadie Hawkins dance was
different from the prom because boys
asked girls to the prom girls asked boys
to the Sadie Hawkins dance
they asked the boy to the dance
something really interesting took place
when the Sadie Hawkins dance went into
effect it became so popular they made it
a national holiday and it became so
popular because parents felt that it was
a safer option because the way the boys
behaved when the girls asked to the
dance was much less aggressive girls
were not crying feeling left out so it
recalibrated these gender norms around
flirting and and dating and courting and
so that was a big inspiration behind
bumble you know when we were thinking
about women making the first move it was
almost the digital rendition of that huh
did you you did or did not like bumble
then when it came up I did not like it
at first and I'll tell you why
bumble sounded like bumble you know you
were you're fumbling through a dating
experience and we wanted this to be an
app that was empowering for women where
they felt confident and in control and
it was not until all of these really
cute catchphrases start started being
you know coming coming up people on our
team and friends when you know we're
asking what do you think about this name
or this neighborhood this name and all
of a sudden these catchphrases were
coming up like you know be the queen bee
of bumble find your honey on bumble
right and it was in that moment that we
said okay this is it this is brand
ability this is how you brand something
and that was that was it off to the
races we went yeah if it sticks it
sticks one of the one of the first
things I asked proofreaders who are
typically friends of mine who are
writers or lawyers because they're
really good at spotting sloppy language
or words that don't need to be there are
things that are confusing in a case one
of the first questions I ask after
they've read a chapter is I will give it
some time say like a half hour have a
cup of coffee I'll say okay what do you
remember and I'll see what's then I'll
see what the first few things know that
come to mind that's really interesting
all right I do a lot about top my like
yeah I don't think about it you are go
and see what stuff if it takes too long
it's like alright I need to rework the
entire chapter no I I think that's very
interesting advice now how many people
roughly at this point use use bubble
I know there are many many many
different metrics and was about it but
we we look at kind of overall user base
in terms of registrations how many times
somebody downloaded our platform how
many people have registered for our app
we've had over 29 million registrations
now in just over three years yeah it's a
lot of people that's good a few people
yeah I saw the part of the beauty of the
of the approach I mean and I know that
there's a lot of complexity hidden
behind a very simple interface believe
me with the amount of time that I've
spent with startups I started using
bumble faire very early on I mean sort
of a nun let's call it alpha or beta but
very early on and what I realized very
quickly is that by having the woman make
the first move you also remove one of
the biggest pain points and you know
this for men which is women receiving
500,000 unwanted messages and even if
prince charming is hiding in there even
if you are the one she would pick it's
too much noise this the the
signal-to-noise ratio is so unfavorable
that as a guy you could put out a
hundred messages and get zero responses
and it just cuts out that first leg of
wasted work completely welcomed so thank
you for that well that's awesome
feedback it's interesting that you
highlight that that just plays into
these gender dynamics you know women
from the time they start thinking about
who they like or having crushes it's
that it's going to be inbound right then
we're trained I think that's gonna come
to us that that the boys are supposed to
chase the girls and and then that turns
into the men chasing the women and and
that we're supposed to essentially play
hard to get and not give in right and so
when the good guy does show up you
oftentimes miss that given those you
know those broken dynamics and so yeah
when you do flip the switch it does
allow it does allow for better and more
genuine connections so people might be
listening or watching and they've read a
bit about your story and you're on top
of the world right in so many ways
stepping up to the plate
home runs every time but you mentioned
when we got started this this depressive
period this dark period so I wanted to
read something that I found in the
course of doing some research and it may
be paraphrased but I think it's it's
somewhat accurate based on checking with
you beforehand but I don't know the
elaboration so the quote here it's from
refinery29 and it talks about how you
wanted to build the company that
encourages empowerment confidence and
respect because when you have
self-respect it's really hard to get you
down this is the part I wanted to dig
into for a second I've been in a place
in my life where I've had no confidence
no self-respect zero self-worth and it
was really easy to hurt my feelings
anything would trigger me to be sad then
when you rebuild some of that you become
stronger so I was hoping you could
describe for us whether it's that
episode that period that you talked
about or another like just one of the
darker harder times sure and what a day
looked like during that time and then
the things you did or the things that
helped you getting out of that
depressive side and this have to be
depressive anxiety could be anything
else um well you know and I still have
days like that and I think that's
healthy for listeners or Watchers to
understand that just because something's
going well or what / you know what
people perceive to be going well it
doesn't mean every day is perfect and I
think the hard times in my life have
really shaped the good times in my life
and I think many people can agree with
that so you know the inspiration behind
bumble was really driven from self you
know self experience and what I've gone
through in my life basically there's
been a common theme with every tough
time I've ever gone through and that
always comes down to mental abuse and
that has been not just in romantic
endeavors that could be friendships
toxic friendships and so there's this
been this recurring theme and you know
when I was under so much scrutiny from
the internet from strangers and I was
allowing these random strangers to
define me and to dictate my day can you
think of any particular example I've
personally I can certainly think of
certain examples unlike
my god that one year when that thing
came out on my birthday and it was a
hatchet job this is can you think of one
where you're like oh god that day so it
was it was actually right after my
birthday funny to say that it was the
summer of 2014 and all of these articles
were running and I hadn't I wasn't
speaking to anyone I wasn't commenting
on any articles I had knew nothing about
the media at that time nothing and I
could not have been more naive when it
came to PR and press at that at that
time and yeah there be dragons got to be
careful yeah and you know this story
came out one morning one afternoon my
dad sent it to me and it was disgusting
it was talking about you know basically
the the piece painted me as this you
know like at the gone girl of tech you
know she was a seductress and the Dada
and all of these awful you know
insinuations and it was talking about
ridiculous things like really personal
details that were completely inaccurate
and it was really gross and ugly and it
just made me feel undressed it was it
was your dad's commentary like well and
that was what was so devastating my dad
was just like you know having your
father send you an article and be like
is this true like of course no but what
you know how do you have to justify that
at 24 just turning 25 years old to your
father
what how how irresponsible can
journalism be that no one asked me for
comment on that you know no one asked if
those allegations were true and to be
this young woman feeling like I was part
of this like mean girl club and you know
the girl that was you know being pointed
out and laughed at by a group of people
I mean it was awful
what was the would the rest of your day
look like I was devastated I I actually
became physically ill so my he's now my
husband and didn't thank God for him he
I was having such a mental breakdown I
was actually having a what they call a
clinical panic attack
I was hyperventilating I was distraught
I couldn't breathe at my sight was not
right and he had to take me to his
primary doctor like his family doctor
and the doctor literally had to
prescribe me one to two days worth of
some what I don't know I don't take any
medicine I'm scared of even Advil but I
think it was like valium or something
you know to physically call me down I
was having a mental breakdown because I
had no way to defend myself and I just
felt helpless and I felt literally
undressed on a huge stage and it was it
was awful
yeah it's not a great feeling at all and
it's even worse I mean it's even worse
for women means bad for men but it gets
even worse I think for women it can be
terrible for men don't get me wrong
talking about very misogynistic things
that really only apply to women and
that's what made it worse you know
making insinuations about who I was as a
woman and my intentions as a woman not
it wasn't even about business if that
makes sense he knows it was very all
that stuff is really salacious and
exciting compared to the business stuff
sick so he's know people like to paint
the picture they got some clicks know
one thing I'd love to chat about it came
up in a number of places when I was
doing homework for this and this is
certainly not uncommon among founders I
know people think oh when the times are
going well you're doing well when the
times are going poorly you're doing
poorly but a lot of founders even when
they're startups are doing really well
have a certain baseline of low grade or
high-grade anxiety so high points tell
me this it's the internet who knows if
this true or not but at some points
you're waking up every two hours to
check your email or you'd wake up at
4:30 check your email then go back to
sleep and wake up again at 6:30 I did
that for years you did that for years
actually that has just now started to
slow down and I have you always have
been anxious is that been sort of an
emotional you know I think it's anxiety
paired with drive and ambition and
passion I'm so dedicated to what I'm
doing I can't explain it to you I mean
it's just part of my blood at this point
and it's almost like a it's built into
my system so yeah that anxiety has been
really scary over the years and there's
days where you know I couldn't feel my
fingers for hours or I didn't think I
could breathe I mean this started
manifesting into physical ailments and
God bless my doctor he's really gonna
have to block my cellphone number at
some point but you know it's it's scary
if you don't deal with the anxiety it
will take advantage it will take control
over your life how have you dealt with
it what are the habits or routines or
self-talk anything yeah it has helped
you to keep it from going from a fuel to
a handicap and something that merely
takes control it definitely has become
my handicap at points but I would say
85% of the time it's a fuel and actually
back to the doctor talk um my doctor
said something really interesting to me
and it's something that's stuck with me
I said to him one day I was like I don't
know if I can deal with this anymore my
anxiety is just so extreme it's
paralyzing me at certain points do I
need to get on a medicine do I need to
be medicated for this and he responded
just keep doing good work
it will it will let you know recalibrate
the way you feel and when I thought
through that and I was like you know
what when I can just if I can channel
this energy and this this anxiety and
channel it into doing good work meaning
work that affects others in a positive
way it genuinely works it actually if
you shift your focus you know it shifted
and you have to you've got to
harness it and control it and my
husband's great about this too you know
he's just like what are your thoughts
let's get your thoughts under control
you know and how do we harness this and
just you know focus on what's causing
this and then how do we shift it into
something that's positive versus you you
know doing the the self-doubt thing on
repeat do you do that with any type of
help like journaling or is it just a
conversation with your husband are there
any when you feel that starting to
spiral I mean do you have pattern
interrupts that you can use yeah you
know I tried to get outside and take a
walk
and leave my phone and I found that
that's really helpful and also sleep not
is more nourishing to your mind body and
soul than a good night's sleep and I
think if you can have uninterrupted
sleep for even if you're if you're a
person that's like oh I only need five
or six hours of sleep if you can try to
have a good seven eight nine hours sleep
it really changes the game yeah one
thing I've also observed said and I
think these are actually very closely
related in some people but that at least
in the for people with depressive
symptoms going to bed before or by say
11 o'clock makes a very big difference
in the quality of sleep in other words
you know sleeping from 2:00 a.m. if
you're it's a self-employed and have
this ability or unemployed from just to
sleep from say 2:00 to 10:00 is not the
same caliber of sleep that you're going
to get from 11 to 8 or 11 degrees so I'm
gonna flash back to books specifically
and set I had read at one point a I
don't think were gonna spend a ton of
time on this right now but you asked
about your team's mood every day which I
thought was very interesting and haven't
have them rank it but what I caught at
the end of this I was curious about so
it says a box in the corner contains
copies of originals subtitle how non
conformists move the world by Adam grant
and Wolff told everyone to take one home
so they can have a group discussion why
did you choose to do that with this book
and do you do it with other books other
other books that you've also used for
employees in the company or yes whatever
it might be so like we were saying
earlier internet time is like different
time zone from every other you know
measure of time when we were doing that
we were a team of something like six or
seven I guess we were really a tiny team
we were still in our apartment and our
conference room was in a bath tub and
you know we were really just trying to
keep the wheels turning and I felt that
a good mechanism of kind of keeping
everyone as fast and as crazy as it was
all going can keep keeping everyone on
some form of a thread of commonality you
know we're there
be something everyone could talk about
together that wasn't bumble right so how
could we how could we have interesting
conversation together as a small team
that wasn't just like okay what are we
gonna do with our downloads or what new
product are we going to do do it how
could we focus on kind of interesting
insights from someone else and so we did
kind of a poll early on what book should
we read together let's try to do a book
club together and this was one of those
pivotal moments of growth and so it did
not last very long the book didn't know
but the intentions were good the
intentions were good and everyone really
liked the idea of trying to turn off
another purpose of that was I was trying
to encourage the team to turn off a
little bit at night sure and instead of
you know getting deep into your emails
after you've come home from dinner open
a book you know read detach do something
that is going to challenge your mind in
a way that you're not being challenged
all day long and so that was the the
premise of it all and you know as you
grow we're now approaching 100 employees
here soon it's very hard to do a check
on you know how you're feeling every day
you can't really go around the room with
you know so many people and it's really
hard to get everybody together for book
club when things are just going so fast
yeah are there any books personally that
you've gifted often to other people or
reread a lot yourself yes I have several
different books but two that we can talk
about something I've always gifted and
just kind of held close over the years
is the book Shantaram have you read
Shantaram okay I became obsessed with
Chantry I'm like I tried to join a
Shantaram fan club online like a book
club it got weird for a second but um
the point is I loved Shantaram and I
loved that it took you into this
different element of you know on human
understanding and I wanted my team to
read it because I think it's actually a
great marketing example how to build a
product based on human behavior and how
to understand people around you and what
makes people tick not just what's the
ROI on some bill
bored right and so I don't know what it
is about that but I can't summarize it
in one sentence but it just gives you a
peek into the soul of humanity if that
makes sense and so that's a book that
I've I've gifted frequently and I love
I'm a fascinating story also the author
has a really good effectively
goodbye public world you're not going to
hear from me for a while I'm going to
continue to do my work but I'm not going
to appear anywhere I'm not going to do
anything made this public Proclamation
which I thought was very inspiring since
I fantasize about that all the time but
this this book a very powerful story
that catches people very often catches
people at the right time what's the
second book so back to the right time
and it catches people thread him I
actually read that book I when I
graduated from college I went and got a
backpack at REI and went to Asia for a
couple - a few months I I have no
concept of years or time anymore and
while I was over there I spent time in
Singapore and throughout several cities
but I also spent time solo at orphanages
in northern Thailand in Cambodia and
then did a lot of travel through that
area and that was the book I read on
that trip and so I think as you are
sitting on this bus that breaks down
with a bunch of local Cambodians eating
crickets reading Shantaram you're almost
taking yourself out of everything you've
ever known to be true and understanding
how big and vast and how great the world
is around you and really how small one
is right you know it just gives you so
much perspective so that's one book
another book that I've been gifting and
he should probably make me an ambassador
so if he listens to this this book
called the plan to paradox have you
heard of it oh this this will destroy
your life in a good way
but so it's basically telling you that
everything you've ever heard about
health and wellness is completely false
so he tells you plants are bad for you
essentially and I don't know what it is
about this book but it might be a little
bit of hocus-pocus but I I'm a full
believer and so I think I've sent that
book
like a hundred people at this point how
is it changed your behavior or well big
thing for me as I've been working so
much I'm also starting to understand how
health catches up so for the first few
years of bumble I mean I was drinking
every night not at a club I mean I have
not gone out I've not been social like a
normal 20-something year old since I
started bumble right actually I became
almost a hermit I became very reclusive
and I just wanted to be with my
boyfriend who became fiance now husband
and I just wanted to be with people that
I really knew and trusted and I didn't
want to go anywhere because I was so
paranoid that everyone hated me or
assumed these awful things about me that
I genuinely just went to work went home
maybe cooked dinner maybe cried a little
bit maybe drank some wine and that was
it and so this health thing has become a
bit more important now you know here you
go to work and you can create as much
success as you're able to but you have
nothing without your health you have
nothing without your mental health you
have nothing without your physical
health and so that's why I'm kind of
getting you know into these these these
books because I think it's important to
have that type of balance has it changed
your diet or anything like that it
actually has it scares you about you
know what you're putting in your body so
it just makes you lose what is your what
might a default breakfast or lunch or
dinner look like for you know oh gosh
that's a crazy question there is no
default is whatever I can find generally
but now I'm going to be more thoughtful
so the rules according to this guy are
that you know everything you put in your
body is essentially your health right
and you are what you eat and so even
getting a piece of organic chicken what
you used to maybe think was good for you
well what is that chicken eating right
you know so it's just this awful rabbit
hole that you go down but it's it's
interesting and it's important to
understand you know the effects on the
planet and you know that's a
conversation for another time
all right cool I'll check it out you
know the everything you put in your
mouth on your body is a drug if it has a
biochemical effect so you have to think
of it that way when you sent the plant
paradox and plants are bad for you there
are a lot of plants that really don't
want you to eat them exactly that's what
yeah there are a lot of them and uh made
me think briefly I'm not gonna get into
it of Zuko who is the creator slash
co-creator I'm not sure which of Zee
cash cryptocurrency really smart guy who
eats only meat I does not eat any
vegetables whatsoever and he's been
doing that for years
see because a lot of the plants have
defense mechanisms and they will poison
you yep yeah they're the Mornington
really well a lot of plants I mean I can
say since they are fixed in their
mobility they can't run away from
predators they develop all sorts of very
very very clever defensive backs I
guarantee beans are toxic for you
yeah beans this we don't have time to
get into the bean rabbit hole the beans
yes this is beans this comes up a lot
I'm not well I'll digress for a second
just because you have very strict like
militant paleo which is like if you eat
beans your GI tract will explode while
you're walking down the street like you
have to be um exaggerate God there's
they're like if you eat beans
it is like swallowing poison broken
glass I tend to I tend to be more
moderate in my views of beans I find
them somewhat helpful also given their
fiber content and so on for a lot of
things including weight loss but if you
look at certainly many different plants
that have something as seemingly
innocuous to say oxalic acid which is
why you get that certain feeling in your
mouth when you eat a lot of say raw
spinach which is can be somewhat
innocuous down to saponins and other
things they can they can actually do a
fair amount of damage but we should
title this episode bumble and beans
Bumble and Bumble and beans or a bar in
Austin yeah right next to mean I'd cat
all right mm-hmm
next question is what purchase of $100
or less it doesn't have to be exactly
that but what purchase that is not
something exceptionally expensive has
has positively impacted your life in
recent memory huh
could be a few years ago could be that's
a great question um coconut oil coconut
oil yes what do you use it for every
you can take a bath with it you can put
it in a smoothie you can cook vegetables
with it you can actually put it on your
skin
I think coconut oil is a cheap miracle
by yeah yeah I agree has some really
fascinating like antifungal antibiotic
properties well every time I crow belie
should say even if you get a cut they
say you can put coconut oil on it and it
helps heal it
yeah coconut oil is is really
fascinating on on many different levels
useful for a bunch of diets maybe that
are contained just because the
concentration of MCT oil effectively but
because the cheap thing you should
always have around you know should one
in your bathtub like next your bathtub
you can put a big scoop of coconut oil
in a hot bath and it just nourishes your
skin and it's actually calming and
relaxing and then you keep on in the
kitchen and do everything with it yeah
coconut oil almost used to cook the
other day but the burning point is not
high not low it's around the same a
bleach and the same as olive oil some
like a smoking points around 350 yeah I
think it can go a little higher than
although apparently olive oils bad for
you I don't yeah yeah for cooking
purposes yeah alright so olive oil
varies greatly
your mileage may vary with your olive
oil purchase system Ferris to you by the
by bumble good good answer
yeah coconut oil also keeps forever this
is very useful time around also little
Smith's in journals so little the little
mini ones they come in yellow with a B I
like to give those to people on my team
and just their low price point I think
they're like sixty dollars for actually
a pretty big one and you can actually
have a monogram yeah and it's just a
nice little leather notebook and I just
think taking notes actually is really
really therapeutic and it is also
incredibly productive I mean you'd be so
shocked and I know that you know this
but I was so shocked when I started just
things down as they came up and the
stuff I was going back to that I written
down I would have never in a thousand
years remembered how to I've written it
down it's fascinating to see how much
the human mind actually just disposes of
in terms of memory and so I think it's
that's a great little gift it it's
really powerful and I mean you're kind
of preaching to the converted since I
have so many notebooks but I think as a
guy especially there's this mental
hurdle with thinking of a journal as a
diary that I just can't leave over so I
can't what but if I like the yellow
pages yes then it serves the same
function I'm really mm-hmm
and you have that Chronicle and it's
it's true that we really think we are
going to remember forever the things
that we will very soon forget and that
was made so clear to me actually when I
was 15 my first time abroad for with any
real time was as an exchange student in
Japan for a year totally changed my life
where are you Joe in Tokyo wow I was the
only ended up the only American in a
Japanese school 5000 Japanese kids see
so if you want to talk about Where's
Waldo school uniform the whole nine
yards every class in Japanese he I was
wild and I had these phone calls with my
mom catching up with my parents and she
would take copious notes every time so
that she could give it to me later and I
look back at those notes and I don't
remember 98% of it I mean now if now I
do as a cue but if she hadn't done that
just would have been gone wow that's
fantastic
oh it's really interesting when is the
last time you cried tears of joy
yesterday yesterday got some big news
can't tell you about it unfortunately
professor but I got some big news and I
got the news in my office with two of my
you know kind of closest allies and very
very early employees and key members of
the team and we all kind of freaked out
and we were screaming in my office and
HR came over and was
what's wrong everyone's worried I
something what's going on in there and
I'm like no everything's great can't
tell you what it is you'll see in a
month but um actually cried tears of joy
it's just it's awesome when when certain
things come up that you felt were so far
away in terms of them being obtainable
or actually happening but you've worked
really really really really really hard
to get there when those two pieces
collide into actual reality it's just
like such an emotional thing I also
cried tears of joy about a week ago so
my husband broke his back in an awful
car accident a year ago exactly a year
ago and he had you know they thought he
was gonna be a quadriplegic they thought
he was maybe gonna die in surgery who
knew what was gonna happen he was in
critical condition for almost a week and
that hospital I mean I just didn't leave
it I stayed in that ICU with him the
whole time and this year a year later he
was fortunate enough obviously he's
walking thank God and he's healthy and
he's well and we went back to the
hospital exactly a year later and he
very generously with his family had
donated the new intensive care center at
the exact hospital and all of his nurses
that took care of him for that week who
were you know literally holding me as I
sobbed and was terrified that they came
to the ceremony and that was just the
craziest feeling to go from being in the
darkest darkest darkest possible
situation in a certain building to
coming back and being in the best
possible situation that's just like a
really emotional situation so I I
definitely cried tears of joy that that
day where were you born and raised Salt
Lake City Utah that's what I thought
so when you're going through this
experience with your husband you're at
the hospital mm-hmm whether you're on
the way there at the hospital during
that period were there any mantras or
quotes or prayers or anything that you
relied on to help or reminded yourself
on it doesn't have to be during that
period but I mean or questions you asked
yourself I'm just wondering if there's
if there's anything that you go to in
moments like that that you find you know
I I do try to tap into whatever the
higher
power is right I'm not a religious
person I do feel that I'm somewhat
spiritual and spirituality comes out in
moments of darkness you know or in
moments of fear and it's interesting you
almost feel this sense of security when
you feel the least secure possible I
don't know how to explain that but it's
really spooky so actually the night
before his accident I actually had a
dream something awful was gonna happen
to him and I called him that morning and
I said I feel sick it was like 6:00 in
the morning I woke him up early and I
said I feel sick I had this awful dream
I need to come home because he was
actually not in Austin at the time and
he was in Tyler where his business is
and so home is kind of we kind of
commute I said I need to come home I
can't go to LA today I've got to get
home I just don't feel good about this
and he was like chill out like I'm gonna
go walk the dogs you go downstairs like
have some coffee call me on your way to
work and I just had this sick feeling
and this really bad feeling like
something's not right something's not
right and I called him on the way to
work and he didn't answer and I just
started sobbing in the car and I had to
kind of slap myself and bolt the window
down be like you're having a panic
attack like this is so you had too much
coffee and I just couldn't calm myself
down and lo and behold five minutes
later you know I got the phone call back
from his chief operations officer who
was following an ambulance and so that
really stuck with me through the whole
week and I was trying to wrap my head
around that I was trying to you know
decipher why did I why am I feeling
those things so my my message and that
not to ramble is that I genuinely
believe every person on this planet has
a sense of intuition and it's learning
how to separate that from fear or
anxiety or panic and really listen to
your gut and I really think that that
that's what has gotten me to where I am
today is that you know listening to your
gut when you can and so yeah that was my
only really mantra I was just to kind of
listen to what was going on and try to
keep it under control so I won't go too
far into this because the people who
don't already think I'm crazy will
definitely think I'm crazy but I think
I'm a psycho
I've been systematically reducing my
caffeine consumption so that there's
less noise
in order that I can better listen to
those feelings because I have found when
I kind of raised the level of volume and
Static with adrenaline and other stress
hormones it drowns out some of the
signal and my dog is also and this is
not that uncommon I mean babies and dogs
I think also but my dog is very much
every time she she never barks she
really rarely barks at anyone and if she
barks or growls at any journalist any
member of the media even when I've
ignored it it is it has within twenty
four hours ended up that I should have
heeded that warning so I used that as
one of my many check boxes of course I'm
using using some more left brain as well
but I am I'm valuing more highly mm-hmm
the less obvious mm-hmm less perhaps
structured thinking because the vast
majority of our evolution is not
prefrontal cortex let's sit down at the
spreadsheet yeah and so if you have a
funny feeling you gotta listen to it
yeah it's worth it's worth exploring
that it's so interesting you say that
because every time I'm like damn why did
I not do that or why did I do that if I
think back to when I made the decision
against her for something I always had
the right answer if that makes sense
yeah but then you go in the other way
for whatever reason and you kind of like
should I listen to myself and for
anybody out there like even in business
I think that's such a good way to have
the answers because a lot of
entrepreneurs we don't have the answers
you know even though I've had this
amazing business partner who has a lot
of answers and I've haven't been able to
tap into his knowledge there's still so
many days where I have no idea what to
do and you're left with one thing and
that's your gut and that's it and you
have to try to listen but I'm with you
on the coffee thing like I've tried to
have only one set because I will
literally start spending out of control
so I'm with you on the toning it down
yet and I mean for for people who are
wondering well how does that actually
apply how do you listen to it I mean in
my case one of the clearest examples if
I look bad
at the 72 and 90 startups that I've
invested in over a 10-year period from
like 2007 to 2017
and a lot of those were passive at any
given time there are no more than like
four or five active needing my help so
it wasn't it was in waves certainly but
and not all four make it as you know how
do you keep track although that's a
whole set we could talk about the whole
separate conversation right now but well
I'll give you one once
one thing that I borrowed from Japan
actually this is getting a little
off-topic but so there's something
called Kate it's in Japan where if you
look at the conglomerates very often
they will buy a company that can be a
supplier or customer for another company
within their portfolio or that has some
type of knowledge it can be transferred
to other divisions so every time I
looked at a portfolio company one of the
ideal boxes to check was how much can
they be helped by and help another
company California is in the portfolio
very smartly and that decreases the it
increases the efficiency for everyone
but also decreases the actual there's a
heavy lifting that I have to do as a
solo operator but when I look at all of
those companies and there's the good the
bad and the ugly within that as you can
imagine the gut feeling and feeling good
about a company or feeling good about a
founder isn't enough for me to invest
but feeling off about a founder is
enough for me not to invest and when I
agree and write so because every a lot
of really good founders are going to
have maybe not a job Xion level the
reality distortion field but they're
gonna be very good at selling yeah and
they're gonna be very good at persuading
and if they're not well guess what that
tells you something too because there
they should be yeah so it's it's very
easy to drink the kool-aid even if you
think you're immune to their charismatic
effects I feel good about it it's like
all right trust but verify
let's get some documents yeah let's look
at the documentation let's actually live
feeling run but yeah exactly whenever
I've violated that which I did in some
of the early cases were saying well we
have this asleep but we have all these
amazing investors we're closing in 48
hours we're over subscribed we can feel
you done all that
[ __ ] tactics and then I invest on and
I'm like [ __ ] new anyway I knew it
then not even the first hour like I knew
within the first five minutes I didn't
feel Yeah right yeah prison okay so
that's enough no that's really
interesting though
mumbo jumbo but yes like good advice to
people yeah seriously yeah there's a
book for people who are thinking that
house might apply more broadly called
the gift of fear by Gavin de Becker
which talks about this and how people
get themselves into very very awful
situations women especially often by not
paying attention to that feeling yet
nagging feeling he's really important
pay attention to what is one of the
bests or most worthwhile investments
you've ever made and that doesn't have
to be money it could be money but it
could be time it could be energy
anything that you've invested into that
gave you a tremendously high ROI the
best thing I've ever invested into is
time and dedication into my team a
bumble that's 100% the best thing I've
ever invested in and you know it's been
such a dedicated effort over the last
three and a half years but really
investing that extra that extra hour or
that extra day or that extra thought or
that extra get to know someone right
that's the stuff that counts the most
because when you do that you instill
more than just a job opportunity you
know you give more than just an opening
at a company you really leave them with
the same values and the mission becomes
ingrained in them and they're able to do
their job in in a way that is almost
immune to competition because they're so
on the same page with why you started
the company to begin with what are what
are some ways that you do that
concretely whether it's in the
onboarding process or ongoing or
otherwise like anything you do on a
monthly or weekly or quarterly or
whatever basis it can you give it an
example yeah so I think that your first
10 hires are what defines
the future of your business because no
singular human can scale culture it's
impossible there's no way to have the
time or the bandwidth or the actual
physical ability to go and instill your
vision and your values in you know
hundreds of employees as things grow if
you're so fortunate so those first ten
people they are your culture warriors
and if you can invest everything you've
got into those people those people will
then invest everything they've got into
the people that work under them or you
know beside them and that's how you
scale culture and so you know in the
early days we're talking weekends like I
would do whatever I could to make
experiences for my my key early hires so
that they felt they felt like family but
in a non boundary crossing way right you
know we still had boundaries right they
still had their own lives and we were
trying to keep things healthy will be an
example of so you know having everyone
over to my house on a Saturday and
making sure that they had a great day
but really explaining to them my pain
points that I lived through in my life
and why this company is going to make a
difference and you know share with them
how we can actually have real impact on
the world not just a paycheck or the
potential to be a big you know valuation
one day right how do we actually change
the world through what we're doing and
changing the world doesn't necessarily
mean you know on the main scale you can
change the world by affecting one person
right that is putting good energy out
there and so investing that mantra and
kind of putting that time and and really
finessing that that ethos has served me
very well and I'm so proud of them
because they're all now leaders in their
own right I'm I want them to feel like
many CEOs of their own in their own way
and you know I if I'm not in the office
for two weeks I don't want you to be
like oh the boss is out because know
there's so many bosses in that office
and they're amazing and they're
passionate and they're inspiring and
they're just as impactful as I am right
to this company and that's how I wanted
it to be what are some of the the rule
or better perhaps his question is what
advice have you been given by mentors or
others that has really helped you in the
early stages of building a company it
doesn't have to be specifically hiring
but it but it could and if that's too
tough or just maybe not an interesting
question just advice that you've
received from mentors or key lessons
you've taken away from any particular
Mentors yeah I've I've received a lot of
interesting advice and I think that the
more you listen and the more you absorb
the better you are as much as I've tried
to say you know I'm gonna do this my way
and your advice is nice and your advice
was great but I'm gonna trust my gut and
I'm gonna build the company that I want
it to be I have gotten great great
pieces of advice from so many people and
I think that my business partner like I
said he had been in the dating industry
for almost a decade before me and so
there were times I would call upon him
and say hey I'm thinking about doing
this and he'd say well I think you
should think about it in a different way
because he had been through it and so I
know this is gonna sound silly but the
best piece of advice I've ever received
was from my husband's grandfather and he
said the most expensive currency in the
world is experienced there's nothing
better than experience you cannot buy it
you cannot pay for it you cannot go out
and get it overnight so tapping into
people with experience and actually
trusting them when you feel that they're
off base but really trusting them that's
been such good advice that served me so
well because you've probably been here
too you know Here I am this like you
know 20-something year old a couple of
years ago I'm still 20
something-year-old but going out and
doing things my own way and saying oh
you just don't understand or I want to
do it my way or no trust me it's gonna
be like this tapping into someone who's
done it before and even if you disagree
with them really thinking twice before
you shut them down and so I just think
that served me pretty well over the
years is to not write off people with
experience yeah this and and furthermore
even if you feel like you're strong
enough to figure it out I mean certainly
looking at a lot of founders I know it
can be it can feel very isolating as a
CEO and I remember chatting with Amanda
Palmer the musician
much more than musician certainly a lot
but if people search Amanda Palmer
asking for help or how to ask for help
it's it's extremely helpful she's given
talks on this as well but I found it
very empowering to realize at times when
I have artificially isolated myself I
don't wanna burden other people with my
[ __ ] like let me just figure this out
and sit down with my a notepad and get
stuck in my head and chase my own tail
and self flagellate and make this all
worse punish myself or feel upset when I
don't figure it all out
absolutely and instead it's like no your
friends want to help you like give them
the gift of allowing them to help you
and even reach your friends yeah you
know they don't have to be afraid even
people that I you know along the journey
I'm kind of have this syndrome worried
I'm always impressed by everyone and I
don't feel impressive ever it's just
it's something I've suffered with my
whole life and you know I've just I've
no matter who it is in front of me I it
literally could be someone that you know
career wise isn't even on the same you
know kind of contribution level or
whatever it is but I'm just always
impressed by people because I think it's
so it's important to really appreciate
everybody else's you know kind of story
and where they've come from what they're
doing and so I've always been the last
few years like you said I've always been
like well I can't ask that person for
advice because they're so important and
they're so impressive and they're gonna
think I'm annoying or they're gonna
think that I'm needy or they're gonna
think that you know what I mean and so
I've almost dug myself into this hole of
not asking enough people for help yeah
in fear of them feeling invaded or
imposed on track not because I didn't
care about what they had to say so
that's a really interesting perspective
and let me give just a couple of
thoughts for people who are like okay
I'm gonna asked him for advice or ask
you for advice or whatever it might be
if you're if you want to ask anyone for
advice who you perceive is very busy one
recommendation I would make is do not
say can I take you out to lunch and pick
your brain yes no one has time for don't
do the brain picking it sounds awful and
nobody wants to do it because it's
really nebulous so the concern is I'm
gonna go out it's not gonna be
15 minutes gonna be an hour of them
trying to figure out what they want to
say and it's not gonna be good use time
so you can if you can say a lie I know
you have get a thousand email if you
don't have time to respond I totally
understand but I I couldn't think of a
better person to reach out to just one
thing I'm really struggling with here's
the situation here's what I've tried to
do or figure out already this is I've
actually used Google yeah right I'm not
guy actually looked into it I've tried
to figure out this and this this is
where I am a super specific question and
again if you're too busy totally get it
no problem and if easier here's my
cellphone I like that that giving them
an out recognizing their busier than
hell which they probably are and having
a really soft delivery but showing that
you've put in some work yes so you're
not outsourcing you're like Mechanical
Turk stuff to them like yeah do you put
in some effort and show you sorry
follow-up to that we actually do that in
the office so what I've told the team
and what the team has really learned and
they're they do it on their own which is
amazing if you have a problem
please don't come talk to me about it
unless you have a suggested solution
exactly yes absolutely
I can't just listen to problems come
with to potential solutions like hey
Whitney we've got a huge issue this
situation has completely crumbled and
we're committed to this or whatever
happened my suggested solution is either
a we do XY and Z or B we could do this
and here are the consequences of both
and this is what is going to happen in
each scenario and then we can talk
through that and it goes to show that
someone has actually thought through you
know the other side of the fire how do
we get out of here what's the exit
strategy not just oh we're in a fire
yeah this is so important and if you
think of problem-solving as an algorithm
or software in a way if you add
headcount to say really inefficient a
software development project it's just
going to make things take longer alright
so the more people you have in a way you
could argue this is really important
especially when you have a tiny team
but the amount of bloat and wasted money
that can really cause problems doesn't
increase in a linear fashion when you
and then have a hundred two hundred five
hundred people if you have five hundred
people who haven't been coached on how
to do this it gets even more expensive
and one thing I'd add to that is yeah
this is so important so when I hire
people part-time contract full-time
whatever it might be they learn really
quickly do not come to me a with a
problem without a proposed solution and
if you come with a proposed solution
don't give me a twelve item
multiple-choice questions yeah you can
give me your top three or four I also
want to know which one do you think we
should do that one which one is the best
and why have you gotten to it and I
might disagree with it but as I put them
I want your top four options or whatever
it might be three in ranked order and
for you to explain why you think number
one is the best yeah and then it's a
yes/no right or now let me take a closer
look it saves so much time and I think
what's important to pair that with and I
remember Reed Hoffman so mm-hmm
co-founder of LinkedIn among many other
things I mean the guy this incredible
investor and and I'll add this I mean
I've had him on this podcast people can
can look it up but he's also a Jif from
what I've experienced of him and many
people have experienced a genuinely
happy guy it's hard to overstate how
rare that is among a lot of these folks
use I don't see people try to get out
there become successful as a as a coping
or you know this is gonna make me
happier this is gonna make me happy and
then they get to the next level and
they're still not happy and then they
want to go to the next level so this is
really amazing yep and and he I mean he
taught Vidkun Stein classes at Oxford
also like in his spare time
he's done a lot and he was the fire he
was called he was referred to as the
firefighter in chief by Peter Thiel and
Reid hired a a young guy named Ben
kaznia to be his chief of staff and to
handle anything and everything it's kind
of like an aide-de-camp position if
anyone from military's listening
in any case what he told been really
early on was and I'm paraphrasing here
but you can have something like a ten to
twenty percent football rate football
just a tennis or sports analogy like you
can have a ten to twenty percent error
rate for the sake of speed like I want
you to move quickly I want you to figure
things out on your own and like you're
allowed to make mistakes I expect you to
make like 10 to 20 percent mistakes and
just try to not make that's your margin
okay and when you tell people that in
advance it it also manages expectations
and it helps to encourage them to do
what both of us are suggesting because
otherwise they're like well I'm if I'm
afraid that I'm gonna be punished for
making every mistake or slight error
then I'm gonna come to you with to try
to get your opinion on everything
because I don't want to get that
negative right suffer that negative
consequence that's really interesting
yeah yeah reads that so just just a few
more what is an unusual habit or absurd
thing that you love and I'll buy a
little bit of time because when I say
absurd or weird I really do mean weird
or absurd so for instance you know I
take a screenshot any time my phone says
555 because I finished my lucky number
555 I screenshot at 555 are you saying
this what about ask my husband I
screenshot if anything is 555 I'm I'm a
weirdo with the number five well if I
see a door that is like 555 I do the
same thing I swear to you that's crazy
I'm not kidding I promise become I've
ever run into anyone else I have a freak
thing with fives all right well we've
the universe has brought us here
no all right so that's one then you have
someone like say Cheryl Strayed he wrote
Wilde and a hugely impressive woman's
when a lot more than that she'll
rearrange sandwiches because she wants
every bite to contain every layer of
said sandwich like it she doesn't want
there to be a clump of avocado on one
half and so on I get that right like
what's understandable it's still pretty
weird so besides your screenshotting
what other odd habits or absurd things
do you do I love well people think this
is absurd I just think it's sweet but
I guess I'm not I'm different I cannot
sleep at night unless I text my mom
goodnight and say I love you oh that's
sweet
I've been doing it since I left home I
cannot sleep at night I have to like
last night I was so exhausted I've been
doing soft buy stuff all day and
literally I had to roll over and get my
phone and say goodnight mommy I love you
I just can't go to sleep without doing
it I know it sounds kind of crazy I'm
literally a grown woman I 28 years old
you know I just I just would never be
able to live with myself if the next day
came and you don't get to see your mom
again for whatever reason and I just
have to say goodnight and tell her I
love her that's a great practice and you
could argue it's even more important the
older you get and I know I would
recommend everybody people people who've
listened this for a long time a
podcaster gonna be sick of hearing this
but read the tail-end by Tim urban
please it really paints an incredible
picture and a sense of urgency as it
relates to interacting with your parents
and I think a number something like by
the time you graduate from it may even
be high school anything it's college
you've like 300 days yeah you've spent
80 plus percent of the time you'll ever
spend with your parents before they die
and so yeah I think more people should
do that so yeah I guess you could call
that absurd because you don't hear a lot
of a lot of adults doing that so it's
probably classified as absurd but I do
think that it's important you know and
no matter how busy you get or no matter
where you are in the world
what what's more important than your
family really yes yeah I've had a lot of
close friends passed away this past 12
months and almost all of them are
entirely unexpected so you just don't
know yeah you just don't know when your
time is up or someone else's don't save
don't save that stuff in the last few
years could be five years two years
doesn't really matter but what new
belief habit behavior tool anything has
most positively impacted your life
personally and not the company not your
employees but you is there any new habit
or belief mmm break through break down
anything that has
ultimately ended up having a very strong
positive impact on your life that's a
really good question
you know what turning my phone off from
time to time genuinely that's helped me
a lot I think I've formed this insane
tech addiction over the last few years
just bumble is on my phone I mean
literally everything goes through my
phone I'm communicating with people all
day every day and it's non-stop and so
turning it off putting it in a drawer
for 30 minutes is actually really
helpful all right it's the last or
second to last question is if you could
put can't be an advertisement but a word
a phrase a quotes question anything on a
billboard some metaphorically giving
this out to millions or billions of
people what might you put well we did it
we put be the CEO your parents always
wanted you to marry and we put that on a
bunch of billboards everywhere we
actually asked that exact question in
the office if we could share one message
with the world and we had a budget to do
it what we put up there and that was
really the sentiment that our team
landed on it just speaks to everything
we're trying to do with bumble we want
to encourage women to be equals and to
be seen as equal and in any courtship
through friendship or business or love
whatever that is to really feel
empowered and confident and to get out
there and be whatever they want to be
not go and try to find that in someone
else you can find that in someone else
but try to do it within also Whitney
thank you so much thank you for taking
the time where can people say hello to
you best places to wave a hand on the
Internet I'll check out what you're up
to
as long as you're gonna be nice on the
Internet come to Instagram but no
everybody what is your handle an
opponent's wit wolf herd and I would
encourage everybody to check out bumble
we've added friend finding business
connections and everything so I think
that would be a great thing for people
to go check out and for everybody
listening I will link to everything in
the show notes as per usual she can find
a Tim da blog forward slash podcast and
until next time thank you for listening
and watching
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by soothe
dot-com the world's largest on-demand
massage service I have been broken so
many times over the years that I usually
have body work done at least once a week
I have a very very high bar for this
type of thing and I was very skeptical
of sooth until I tested them not once
but I would say at least a dozen times
around the country in different cities I
do not accept anything less than
excellent for any type of soft tissue
treatment and would not suggest that you
accept anything less than excellent so I
can affirm personally that soothe
delivers a licensed experienced and
above all effective in my book massage
therapist in the comfort of your own
home hotel or office in as little as an
hour so you can think of it as uber for
massages available and 55 cities
worldwide at this point across the US UK
Canada and Australia so you can relax
just about any time any
we're and I've tried many different
types of massage that they offer in the
process is super super simple
download the soothe app that's soo th e
or go to suit comm choose the kind of
massage you want you can select Swedish
sports deep tissue or even couples
massage I usually give deep tissue
myself or I'll do couples massage and
then tell both of the therapists that
I'm actually intending to get a
four-handed massage instead of having
two people get two-handed massages that
make sense then you set the length of
your massage whether 60 90 or 120
minutes if you're looking to get fixed I
usually do 90 or ideally 120 you select
the gender of your therapist and then
boom you're done and you will see who
picks up the call the service is
available from 8 a.m. to midnight and
soothe brings everything that you need
to create a spa experience in your home
and the therapist handles all of this
the massage table linens oils music the
whole nine yards so try it out download
soothe and as a listener of this show
you'll get twenty five dollars off of
your first massage when you enter the
code ten twenty five all caps TGIM to
five again download the suit app and use
the code
Tim twenty five for your twenty five
dollar discount this episode is brought
to you by freshbooks man oh man do a lot
of listeners of this podcast and readers
of mine love fresh books to the extent
that I ended up meeting with the CEO not
very long ago why are they so popular
well they are the number one cloud
accounting software designed exclusively
for self-employed professionals that's
many of you and used by more than ten
million people you can send invoices
track your time and get paid very very
quickly which suits the needs of a lot
of freelancers a lot of fonts my blender
Lowe's and beyond you can take pictures
of receipts you can link your credit
card any debit cards so all the things
you buy automatically appear in your
fresh books in the right category so on
and so forth makes taxes easy makes
invoices easy makes your life easier and
also in fact I recommend a PDF they
didn't ask me to read this part by the
way they put the other PDF a while back
called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you
search for breaking the time barrier a
lot of people ask me how can I get a
four hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life
enjoy
[Applause]
you